what sort of Life advice has family
imparted on
you life advice um like what what do
they want me to like do when they
like what sort of Life advice does
family give women today you know the
question is for both of you you know
when it comes to choices that you're
making
um so life advice well I'll think about
like my grandmother my my grandmother
was um always telling me that I should I
should get like a good career and I
should I should go with that but she's
also told me like her and my and my um
late grandfather they had a beautiful
marriage and they very much had like the
gender roles in there and I got to
witness that and she's from a very young
age told me like you are going to be
beautiful and you're going to be sweet
and you're going Pleasant and your
marriage will will will flourish but
she's also told me that like I should
get um a good career she's never been
too particular about what that is but um
she's also just said to she's given me
dating advice she all she'll every time
I see her she'll be like she's very
Catholic and she'll be like I'm praying
that God send you a good man I'm praying
God sends you a good man because I mean
I'm 24 I have a biological time clock I
mean I'm well aware but I'm just I'm I
think that I in this time like I know I
should be looking I just don't really
know how to be going about that I don't
really like to I guess just put myself
in the in situations I just don't know
where to start really but is Hope a
terrible plan like he's just gonna go
up is is Hope a a terrible plan yeah
like is he just going to just show up
one
day
um I don't I don't think so
no so what's the
plan I don't know I really I I I don't
know because the only way I could think
of is I mean ideally me and the women in
my Bible study we've always said that we
wanted to meet a man at church that's so
ideal for us but um are there no men
that go to church that are single and in
the age range that you would want to
date and attractive they are all of the
I'll put it this way all the cute ones
are married already like all the all of
the the cute ones they a lot of men are
already already married at least in my
church but you say cute do you like is
that from the Optics of Attraction
like a handsome sort of cute or handsome
yeah that's what I mean by that or does
cute like for women involve uh success
pedigree
influence
captivation I think well that that
matters obviously but whenever I see an
attractive man in church I don't know
those things yet if I okay let's say if
I if I see an attractive man in church
and he's single and I um go about
getting to know him and he is it he
doesn't make a lot of money or he
doesn't he's not very ambitious oh he
doesn't make enough to lead a family in
a way at least um then I would have to
take a step back and look at things
because that that doeses matter I'm not
going to sit here and say that it
doesn't so the cute ones are married the
ones that are unmarried are dorks or
where
um I don't they're not marriage material
they're not
husbands right and and I I can't I don't
even want to say that because it's not
like I'm like speaking to them I don't I
don't know anything about them does
anybody speak to this men speak to these
men and say hey look if you want to
attract a Rachel
who's of the same faith and in the same
congregation sort of thing this is what
you need to become like these are the
cute guys that are married this is what
you need to do to accomplish this does
anybody speak to these
men that's interesting because um in my
church there's a lot of small groups and
they have small groups um a lot of them
tailored for just men and then they have
different ideas for like different like
main premises that they go off of like
they have a business one they have one
for working out they have some for like
activities and I'm curious um as if
that's something that they talk about as
a as if like for the single men as far
as finding a woman along groups for
working out for hobbies like what sort
of hobbies yeah um I don't know I don't
know much details about it one of my
co-workers actually um who got me into
my church he's a guy and he was in the
small groups but he was in the business
one but he did tell me that they had
other ones for other Hobbies I just
didn't know which ones the business
group is it like BNI sort of like
networking hey I've got a dental
hygienist sort of practice and I do this
and electricians and I'm a plumber and
they sort of network that way yeah yeah
it's a it's a networking thing but it's
a it's a b is there any emphasis put on
scaling up and making like impact in
serus bank
or swapping business cards I think so I
think so okay seems
I've seen in my experience like I've I
don't I'm not a part of the church
anymore um I went when I was growing up
just a bit and I think one of the things
is common and what's interesting in in
Rachel like you I remember you coming on
the show and I think the sole reason we
got connected in the first place because
you said you were a follower like you
had dated somebody who was a follower
and then you of Rich of stuff and the
content and then you sort of started
watching and you agree with a lot of
stuff that we talk about but what I've
seen I think in increasingly across
churchgoers and church members even but
even when I was in the church and when I
was growing up in my teens and early
20s the kinds of things that we talk
about the kinds of things that I've
learned through rich and through reading
books and through even you know
navigating the world through an
unplugged lens are very dissimilar
almost at odds with a lot of the
teachings and the things that I saw and
that I see men that are in the church
continue to learn I mean I've even got a
member in my community who's writing a
book about sort of the relation the at
ODS relationship between modern
Christianity which seems to be pacifying
and pussying men and sort of unplugging
slash the red pill these sorts of things
so I'm curious and it's it's interesting
to me I
wonder if what you're looking for is
becoming a ever shrinking sort of Dying
Breed of a man that embodies sort of
these traditional masculine leadership
traits who's also a Christian when those
kinds of things and those kinds of men
that are calibrated that are being
leaders are actually moving away from
sort of traditional Christianity sort of
the church so that's what that that's I
don't know that's kind of a thought it's
not really a question but I
wonder if that's something you've
thought about where you're running into
these kind of guys that are sort of
fitting the bill but they may not be
fitting the Christianity bill but the
guys that are fitting your Christianity
Bill aren't fitting the rest of it and
if you get to a point where it's you
know either or kind of kind of What's it
gonna
be I well I'm open to being with
somebody that would be willing to learn
more about my faith and or and at least
just be supportive of that but I I I
really just cannot see see myself with
somebody that is just doesn't that's an
atheist like just straight up doesn't
believe at all um I just don't think I I
really don't think I could do that and
I'm not g to I I know that it's a small
pool but it's also not impossible um so
I I'm going to be hopeful in that
sense so it's easier for you or
preferable for you to take an unplugged
guy and sort of bring him to the light
versus take
a Christian guy and try to teach him all
this all this stuff if you had choose
between it's not something yeah no this
is it's not my responsibility to teach a
man those things he should he should
have Outlets that teach them those
things and and and know those things so
women just want guys to get it just get
it I don't want to figure it out figure
it out for you like it's just like you
it's you get it or or you don't it's
that that and you I can tell that very
early on whenever I start um talking to
a guy before I meet him or something
like you can tell
yeah there's um there's a side
conversation going on here in the live
chat this guy Christianity unplug said
most Church ladies I run away from so I
asked him why in the chat while you guys
were discussing that and he responded
with um they tend to be and
pretend Holiness single mom issues fake
feminine eals or complementarian
problems end up emasculating men I think
that's one of the Grievances a lot of
guys have expressed that I've heard
anyway um is that there's you know a lot
of gals that are in the church but they
don't subscribe to the rule book you
know for example um in most you know
religions up until marriage it's
expected the women you know to be chased
you know to be virgins you know on their
wedding day um and that's kind of gone
out the window you know in almost all
scenarios but the other things that they
talk about as well like they masculate
men they run guys like a lot of the
churches are are encourag enaging women
to become more masculine sort of thing
so I think there's a lot of a lot of
guys out there that are feeling
um a distance from their faiths that
they might have grown up in or might
have subscribed to it at some point not
really like I don't know if you guys
want to comment on that but it's just an
observation that I've uh seen well more
Society than churches I think I feel
like Society is yeah I agree what do you
mean Society versus churches like I I
feel like that's just Society in general
is pushing women to be more of that
masculine role yes you know rather like
I I'm not saying that you know that
person churches you know the women in
those churches it's they are just it's
not the churches that are doing it it is
more of it's culture yeah so but but I
me like you can see the Grievances that
they might have with that because
because if religion and church and faith
says something simple like you know you
must remain chased to your wedding day
you know for your husband but society
and culture and media and Hollywood and
music is like indulge go out have fun
act like a man you know share yourself
with a whole bunch of dudes you can see
why there's you know these conflicts
that exist and why guys start to walk
away from religion and faiths too
right I I mean yeah absolutely that the
devil's going to lead you to you know
the more hiding
fun type of
Lifestyle you know rather than a but
don't women have agency like don't they
have the ability to make decisions for
themselves and follow absolutely you
know the rule book yeah but they
don't I mean yeah that's what being
human is like we're not you know we're
not perfect I really hope you guys enjoy
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out